el huracán grace ha prácticamente pasado
durante más de 12 horas por mérida por
la península de yucatán está la tarde
noche de ayer jueves comentarte que
bueno que las mayores afectaciones
fueron ráfagas de viento de más de 120
kilómetros por hora casi 120 kilómetros
por hora esto ha sido los vientos más
fuertes que se han sentido en los
últimos 19 años luego de isidoro en el
2002 comentarte que más allá de la
lluvia lo que ha dejado demasiados
destrozos como bien te comento con esta
los árboles caídos letreros caídos y
postes prácticamente en el suelo por
varias vialidades importantes de mérida
y sobre todo en el cono sur de la
entidad de yucatán y en el oriente de
yucatán más o casi medio millón de
yucatecos se quedaron sin luz y sin
comunicación la tarde noche de este
jueves hoy en mérida prácticamente en
calma sin embargo aún hay elementos del
ejército mexicano
guardia nacional de la secretaria de
seguridad pública y de protección civil
a lo largo del oriente del estado y de
la ciudad de mérida donde puedes ver aún
permanecen en árboles en los pisos
árboles en las calles que tendrán que
poco a poco irse despejando